me I got something to find I got
something hilarious Tom me later oh okay
okay do you want to say it say did you
just forget we're doing a podcast right
now no you know the the sushi restaurant
the one that we all love and care about
deeply Emily said it was mid and
overpriced oh my God she did not she did
not wait who said that Emily and daer
said that it was a mid and they thought
they got scammed because it was so
expensive oh my God that's okay that's
fine that is not okay me no no no I
don't know a single you're never going
to watch this episode but I don't think
they can tell the difference I don't
think they I that that was the moment
that I I genuinely lost all hope in
their food T you know D like thought
Gregs was mid I just I just I've never
been so disappointed
before yeah but he was also on a steady
diet of [__] microwavable food in the
US as well so like I don't trust them
they have the weirdest food taste asle
it's like impossible to give them
something [__] made for each other but
but what the [__] but not made but not
made for everybody else can't believe
thought that Sushi was made that's
that's going to keep me up at night I
can't that's like my favorite sushi
place go I have a I have a friend who's
visiting right now who's like like the
who's like born in Texas and he just
can't have seafood and he was asking me
for like restaurant recommendations and
I'm like [__] if you can't have seafood
what can you recommend in Japan that
doesn't include Seafood as well [__]
this is a lot harder than I thought it
when I out with um uh you think that's
hard Mudan when Mudan came his group
some of his friends came over and one of
them had uh CX disas couldn't have
gluten I learned that day that when I
was trying to find a restaurant [__]
everything in Japan has gluten
everything everything soy sauce gluten
Meo gluten often is gluten intoler like
is there even a full Japanese person
that has gluten intoler like is that I
think I think they it got like they were
killed I think I think they they they
surv the fittest well no I think if you
had celex disease in like [__] I
don't know I I don't know the history of
it but I imagine it's like a thing where
well he
died Skil it's it's called Uh Evolution
right bro Darwin knew it Darwin figured
it out this the reason why uh I'm I'm
not lactose intolerant H and uh one of
you guys speciically probably are
lactose in to I'm slightly lactose in to
do do you think that if we were born in
like the caveman era that You'd Survive
or would you would you be one that died
off thanks to survival of the fittest
why are you saying this God everyone
loves to think that they could survive
but whe oh no I'm saying I'm [__]
because I can't see [__] okay I think be
the first to go I think it'd be okay I
know them their music uh we we get along
I like I like smashing things I mean
like even if the thing is like even if
you were like know that music music took
me a while to process this smash some
rocks yeah H I think I'd be okay as a
caveman I think I'd be all right I think
the problem is that even if you had the
perfect genes as a caveman that could be
compatible with that time period the
average [__] life expectancy was like
27 so like that's my life expectancy
right
now last trash by the
way oh my God uh the answer is no I
would not I think it' be okay you think
we'd be okay I think I'd make it work
cuz I wouldn't know Beday exist I
wouldn't I wouldn't have anything to
like care about
yeah I just I feel like my my priorities
would be way different the biggest
animal you think you could take on then
like one V one fight you you have
weapons though you have weapons you have
a weapon what kind of weapons like like
like caveman weap you can take any
animal on with with weapons are you
kidding me that's [__] that's why
we're on top baby a a sharp Rock on the
end of a stick Stone Age Stone AG
weapons [__] gun yeah okay of course
if you have a gun you could take on any
animal wait where am I spawning huh
where am I spawning
what you mean what country is my spawn
point what country is your spawn point
uh not England okay well that's fine cuz
some a lot of we if we're in a volcanic
we're in a volcanic country there's
obsidian very very sharp by Nature I'll
pick some pieces up I throw it at the
animal we're good that's all that's all
you throw it at the animal bro are you
kidding me that's all I'll be doing my
entire life is throwing things cuz that
is our one trait that makes us the most
OP is that we can throw [__] we no no
other no other animal can throw [__]
like us yeah he's definitely dying for
what do you mean that is that is the
reason why we were so op as as humans
cuz we can just like sit back and
[__] launch things no we we were op
because we were smart well no no we w we
weren't smart for a very long time no
I'm kidding we were smart because we
managed to think that guy is that far
away I got a stone here I wonder if I
throw it at him and run away we're also
very good Runners we're not fast but we
have like like not many other species
can like run as long as we can if we we
have the stamina yeah cuz like a deer
and [__] can't run that long they can
run a they can run very faster they can
run faster than a tiger and a lion
that's all that's important right uh
yeah sometimes
sometimes listen we throwing [__] is so
valuable no I agree throwing [__] is
valuable I asked I asked you what the
biggest what what's the biggest anal
what's the biggest animal you think you
take Spears and I can take down an
elephant no [__]
no all right Sabertooth could you take
on a
sabertooth uh I probably wouldn't be
able to he'd catch me yeah for the
moment I throw one spear I'm gone an
elephant though what the [__] do you
think you could take on an elephant I
just feel like I could probably get
enough Spears down no that the skin is
like tough as [__] on that thing yeah
but if you have a really sharp thing
You' be all
[Music]
right list listen I've played Elden ring
right I can I can dodge and roll around
the elephant his his AE you don't have
frames [__] I don't have ey frames I
think I think maybe with enough Spears
if I was really really really dude
imagine imagine how happy The Village
would be there if I brought back an
elephant I'm like guys I'm going to need
everyone to come out for this one we got
a we got a whole ass like why why what
yeah I mean I'm sure but like I don't
think like throwing a couple of Spears
is going to take it down I think have a
good good crack at
it it's like the new season of Tas like
so how did die so he just decides to
Chuck the spear at the [__] Elephant
D you could dig a really big hole and
like lead the elephant into the hole
well like like like a Loney
tun like a wild coyot kind of how deep
are we talking right now like if I dug a
6ft hole that is like just wide enough
for two legs of the elephant to fall
into yeah it'd be stuck right it no way
it' get out what you mean what no wait
wait are are you talking about [__]
implanting the elephant with four
different holes for each no no like it
one giant hole that could theoretically
fit two elephant legs right and like a
bit of its it buttocks and if it went in
over the the thing right I put leaves
like a Lune skit and it walked over I
let it maybe I stabbed it and ran over
it Jing it would fall into it didn't
know it's a
hole I think it would fall in and if it
fall in it wouldn't be able to get out
cuz there's no how's the elephant going
to climb out oh you talking about if it
like Falls in and lands on its back no
no just like even if its legs went in
cuz I don't no cuz then it could just
back up and just be
like or or it would continue to walk
forward and just [__] walk out what
if it I no I think it's too top I think
it's too heavy I don't think the only
that that would work is if the hole is
the length of the elephant and it just
like Falls no I think I think a looney
tun's comically half hole the elephant
would work have you not seen an elephant
stand on two legs yeah it could get out
that
way okay okay now okay okay we're
doubling the size of the would you
reckon it would fall in there it's not
like it's not like link like old school
link where it can't jump like it can it
can it can jum not that just I'm just
imagining caveman con of being like boys
perfect plan we have a hole it it starts
like getting up on his hind legs this
[__] jump I think I think we
get enough if there was four of us we
could get enough stabs in to to to take
the elephant down it take a lot of stabs
that's the reason they had war elephants
back in the day man they actually
weren't that
effective were they not I don't think
they were that effective well like the
the Persian Empire and stuff like that I
don't think they were that effective
yeah I think it's pretty easy to take it
down man watched one one film of like
300 oh my throw speed
hard right there there's 30 of the boys
together with their Spears and shields
right the Elephant Rocks up I think we
all collectively are like we're going
for the elephant we're going for the
elephant everyone throws their spear you
land enough Spears in the thing L you
won't walk anymore no no no no because
like if you have a group that's
different because you would like you
someone would have to like take aggro
while like everyone else is likeing
spear juggle the ago bro no literally
you would have to like juggle the aggro
that's what you would have to do bro all
right switch up load up reload next wave
yeah yeah
yeah do you think kman had that level of
[__] life obviously they they took
Downy mammoths and yeah but they they
probably took it down in great numbers
like it wasn't they weren't like Min
maxing that [__] oh no no they
definitely were Joey if your life was on
the line you came in a dumb you you yes
they are no they weren't dumb all they
did was that's why we evolved to now
where we're talking about this the
moment it all Chang some ones Joey
that's why I'm saying I would not
survive the only that made the the only
time we stopped carrying is when we
figured out like farming yeah they were
like well guys I guess uh hunting's kind
of pointless now yeah all we got to do
is just shoe flies away and Stu like do
you think like caveman cavemen use any
brain capacity to figure out [__] the
economics of like their country or [__]
or like how black holes work no that all
they were focusing on was how to take
down his
yeah was how to take down this [__]
animal and survive listen I reckon even
two of us could take down an elephant I
think all right that's B that's
that's I I was thinking like 5 10
minimum I think a 10 of you it'd be easy
yeah that's what I'm saying that's
probably what they did um they saw they
saw the size of this giant [__]
creature and they were like well uh you
know Steve isn't going to take it on by
himself we we should get everyone in on
this [__] I just think fishing just
sounds a lot easier yeah what in land
yeah true true hope you got a pond or
something yeah yeah just hope you spawn
in the right place right yeah well most
places they most places most places were
water water most of people did tend to
go near the water yeah even they didn't
spawn there just see that's why the
Japanese figured out farming immediately
and then were like oh wow this is so
much easier they figured out yeah they
like oh rice it can it can feed everyone
and we don't have to [__] hunt for
this
[__] I suppose so yeah they figure it
out if you were actually like if you
were actually stuck in a battle royale
which character archetype do you think
you'd be like honestly honestly what do
you mean by character archetype you know
you've seen [__] Battle Royale you've
seen squid game you've seen Battle
Royale literally there are character
archetypes there okay Jo I wouldn't be
the I'd be the sniper I would be the
Archer yeah but I think I'd be a bit if
I was if I really was in it I think I'd
be a bit indifferent towards the killing
after a while I'd be like well I see the
me or them I guess so yeah but I mean
okay here's here's here's the thing
right because you you know we' like to
think that we'd be ex character y
character but you get one shot you know
you get you get one you you don't get a
million [__] Dark Souls tries you
don't get to figure out if ey frames
exist you don't get to figure out you
know the boss attack patterns and all
that [__] you get one chance you know so
like I'm you know I'm thinking most
people would just probably Camp it out
yeah I would be like the the like wussy
hoarder I just like gather everything
and just monopolize all the I dig a 7ft
hole and I leave people into the 7ft
hole like CU in in every like Battle
Royale [__] show like it's like the
you know the [__] Chads that like you
know go out and kill people that always
come out come out on top but to me I'm
just like surely they're easy targets
right surely they're like no those those
types of guys are the ones who in a real
life situation they're going to die
first I mean realistic you just make a
team just try and make a team that's
your best bet right just get a part of a
where are we dropping
boys you just pray the first people you
meet are kind of chill and then they it
works out that's uh I think I'd stake my
bet on that I'd be like well my life is
on this 50/50 I don't know man I've
watched squid game it didn't work
out one of going to betray you if you
incentivize killing each other then yeah
I guess though but if you don't then you
know I guess talking like like an
apocalyptic like survival situation
right yeah yeah oh yeah obviously yeah
fine yeah I guess okay that's different
cuz like zombie apocalypse is different
from like a battle royale kind of like
situation but you might need to kill
someone to get their
food uh you mean in zombie apocalypse or
it's just any apocalypse someone's not
going to give their food but you're
about to you know you desperately need
food or water you
know is that what you were like during
Co I was I was going to kill goddamn
food my bathtub is not feeling sorry
sorry
God if a zombie apocalypse happened
you'd be that [__] in like
episode four or whatever in Last of Us
yeah he's like all right guys I'm going
to go and then immediately die just like
holding up and being like this is my
place right now you cannot come in I
have a working b day right here and is
not for sharing actually I mean
theoretically there'd be enough oil if
you could get a hold of it and generate
it you could probably like live if you
got super lucky you could live
comfortably yeah be very tough you can
at least get a few good years that's my
biggest problem with Zone 100 they they
just have working electricity yeah I'm
like I'm like how how oh we theom
running the zombies killed everyone but
the uh the workers at the power plant as
long as they never leave yeah it's so
convenient it's like we everyone is a
zombie except the essential
workers cuz we need them they're not
animals they're just
zombie they're like oh you run the the
you run the plan the you are the first
to die